كانت الساعات الاثنتين والسبعون الاولى من
حدوث زلزال سوريا وتركيا الاكثر حرجا
بالنسبه للعالقين تحت الانقاض
غير ان المعدات اللازمه للانقاذ
والمساعدات الانسانيه حالت دون وصولها الى
الشمال السوري تحديدا مناطق سيطره
المعارضه الاكثر فقرا وفي هذا الشان راى
الصحيفه فاينلانشال تايمز ان بطء وصول
المساعدات الدوليه اكدت تلك الاتهامات
التي تطال نظام الاسد وهي ان دمشق نجحت
مره اخرى في تحويل اهتمام العالم بمعاناه
شعبها الى استثمار مربح يعود بالنفع على
النظام واتباعه
تذكر وثائق تم تسريبها في عام 2016 ان
الامم المتحده اضطرت سابقا لتوظيف اقارب
مسؤولين رفيعي المستوى في النظام
يجب ان تكون هناك عمليه سياسيه حقيقيه
يقودها السوريون وتسهلها الامم المتحده
ويجب ان يكون هناك جهد دوري منسق لدعم ذلك
مع عمل جميع اللاعبين الرئيسيين في جهد
متماسك
ابنه حسام لوجا رئيس المديريه العامه
للمخابرات السوريه الذي تعاقبه الولايات
المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي والمملكه
المتحده بسبب انتهاكات حقوق الانسان هي
مثال بات معروفا لهذه الضغوط التي يمارسها
النظام على المنظمات الاغاثيه البنت
العشرينيه والعهده على الصحيفه تعمل في
مكتب الصندوق المركزي لمواجهه الطوارئ
التابع للامم المتحده في دمشق
توظيف اجباري تتبعه اقامه الزاميه لموظفي
الجمعيات الاغاثيه في احد الفنادق
المملوكه من رجال اعمال مقربين من النظام
فمنذ عام 2014 دفعت الامم المتحده 81
مليون و600 الف دولار لاقامه موظفيها في
فندق فور سيزونز في دمشق المملوكي لسامر 4
رجل اعمال فرضت واشنطن عقوبات عليه وعلى
الفندق في عام 2019 بسبب ارتباط علاقاته
الماليه بالاسد
ويشير تقرير فانشال تايمز الى ان النظام
يفرض معضله اخلاقيه مستحيله امام المنظمات
الاغاثيه بين اللعب وفقا لقواعد الحكومه
او وقف المساعده عن سوريين محتاجين